Student Rodith asks, "How do we go about finding a good seed page?"
>>This is a really good question,
we haven't solved that question in this course, and we won't.
We're going to give you a seed page and have exercises and--
sets of pages to crawl set up so that seed page will work well.
For a real web crawler, this is a big challenge.
And they don't start with just one seed page;
they start with a set of many seed pages that are selected in different ways.
Some may be found by hand,
by people identifying them as good seed pages,
some may be the results of previous crawls,
so once you start crawling the web, you don't just stop--
you keep crawling the web and you build a new collection of pages,
which you can start using start using as seed pages.
But this is a hard problem--to get a good collection of seed pages--
to cover as much content as you can find on the web.